breaking bad's grand epilogue El Camino
is full of references to the beloved
show that preceded it some more obvious
than others if you're too busy freaking
out that you finally got more Breaking
Bad here are some small details in El
Camino you may have missed beginning in
the second season of Breaking Bad Walt
and Jesse were frequently aided and
abetted in their illegal misdeeds by
crooked lawyer Saul Goodman who operated
out of an unassuming office located in
an Albuquerque strip mall at the end of
the series saw abandoned his legal
practice and ran for his life starting
over with a new identity in Nebraska if
you look closely there is a brief call
back to Saul early on in El Camino
during the night Jesse spends crashing
at skinny Pete's house in a series of
brief time-lapse shots showing the Sun
rising over Albuquerque were treated to
three shots of different locations in
the city the second shows a nondescript
strip mall but if it looks familiar
there's a reason for that one of the
businesses shown is Duke city sports bar
which resides in the same location that
used to house Saul Goodman and
associates Gus fring is long dead by the
time El Camino rolls around successfully
killed off by Walt in season four while
several other characters who perished
over the course of Breaking Bad's still
managed to make an appearance in El
Camino Gus is not among them however
there is a blink and you'll miss it nod
to the show's greatest antagonist in the
same early-morning sequence when we
glimpse Duke city sports bar right after
the camera reveals the new business
occupying Saul's former office space it
shows a fast-food restaurant named
twisters twisters is in fact a real-life
restaurant in Albuquerque which provided
both the interior and exterior shots
formal spoils and Amano's and Breaking
Bad in El Camino it would seem that the
fictional restaurant has since morphed
into its real-life counterpart we take
pride in everything that we do one of
the pivotal moments in Breaking Bad
occurred in the first half of season 5
on the heels of Walt and Jesse
successful train heist which they
carried out with Todd's help while they
were still riding high from the robbery
things took a sharp turn when they
crossed paths with a young boy who'd
been out riding his bike in a desert and
just happened to come across the
criminal trio although the child hadn't
commit a crime Todd still shot and
killed him over Jesse's frantic protests
later arguing that no one was supposed
to know that they'd been in the desert
at all how does this connect to El
Camino it's subtle but before the boy
was killed he came across a tarantula
which he scooped up in a glass jar
presumably to keep as a pet in El Camino
Jesse sees that Todd has a pet tarantula
perhaps the very same tarantula which
keeps in a desert-like terrarium in his
room when he returns after Todd's death
a saddened jesse feeds the tarantula no
doubt thinking of the child he was
unable to save throughout the five
seasons of Breaking Bad characters
repeatedly hid things in places where
they hoped no one else would ever find
them stashing stuff and created places
only to later have to move them or risk
someone else finding them was a
recurring motif of the show so it was
only fitting that El Camino includes its
own riff on the familiar theme when
Jesse rips apart Todd's apartment in
search of his drug money after Todd
moves it out of his world book
encyclopedias one of the first places
jesse looks is under Todd's kitchen sink
the location should be a familiar hiding
place for eagle-eyed Breaking Bad fans
since that's where Jesse hid his stash
of meth in season two's frantic mandala
of course the meticulous Todd had been a
little more inventive than Jesse and had
actually hidden his cache in the door of
his refrigerator but Jesse's beeline for
the sink was most certainly a callback
to the earlier days of the show before
Todd was a drug dealer and casual
murderer he was an exterminator working
for vamonos pest while vamonos pest was
a legitimate pest control company its
crew would often supplement their income
by stealing from the houses they were
fumigating or granting access to other
criminals for a price vamonos was
eventually purchased by Walt Jesse and
Mike as a front for their meth cooking
operation and as a result Todd became
increasingly entrenched in their
business before turning antagonist El
Camino includes a subtle nod to Todd's
pre Breaking Bad profession and the
scene where the two candy Welding
company employees search his apartment
for his money pretending to be police
officers when KC walks into Todd's
bedroom which Jesse had utterly
destroyed in his frantic search for
Todd's cash
Todd's vamanos
uniform can be seen in the foreground of
the shot although the logo is only half
visible it's a stark reminder of how
disastrous Heisenberg's partnership with
vamonos pest ultimately proved to be
with todd walt and mike all winding up
dead Jessi fleeing to Alaska
when Jesse realizes he's $1,800 short of
what he needs to start a new life he
decides that instead of asking his
friends or robbing his parents instead
go to the men of candy welding company
who are as deep into illegal activity as
Jesse ever was earlier Jesse convinced
Neil candy to split Todd's money with
him three ways knowing that they both
had a vested interest in not doing
anything that would draw the attention
of the police
although Jesse only asks for $1,800 a
relatively small amount considering
Neil's take was likely somewhere in the
vicinity of a quarter of a million
dollars a coked-up meal suggests that
the two of them decide who gets the
money in a winner-take-all old-fashioned
shootout at the Wild West yeah
like the Wild West Breaking Bad has
often been referred to as a modern-day
Western and this scene could easily be a
nod to the genre that inspired much of
the aesthetic of the series however the
Wild West reference may be doing double
duty possibly also winking at Aaron
Paul's upcoming role in HBO's Westworld
another show that offers a postmodern
take on classic Western tropes although
little is known about Paul's role on the
sci-fi series as of the making of this
video his mention of the Wild West and
El Camino may not only be tipping his
hat toward the show he's leaving behind
but also the one yet to come
dude you have fire check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]